Miley Cyrus stripping down a glittering  up and a growing wings for a special new  project  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  here's that image again Miley in the  buff save for some strategically placed  glitter looking ethereal as some sort of  butterfly fairy hybrid in a prison cell  the Technicolor shot is actually the  cover of celeb photographer David  LaChapelle's new book of photography  lost-and-found do whatever you want to  make everybody look it's the famed  photographers at first book of photos in  a decade and it features get this a  hundred and fifty unpublished works by  the artist of course Miley is just one  of many muses in the edition Rihanna  Amber Rose Lady Gaga and Naomi Campbell  are all also featured in the coffee  table book set for release this December  yet turn it out